[MUSIC PLAYING]
MALE SPEAKER: Oven
mitts for sale.
Oven mitts.
Oven mitts for sale.
TODD KERPELMAN: Oh.
Why, hello there, sir.
I could use an oven mitt.
In fact, I'll take two.
MALE SPEAKER: Here you go, kid.
Enjoy.
TODD KERPELMAN: All right.
Thank you.
This is just what I needed.
This is-- huh.
Hey, what's up with this?
MALE SPEAKER: Oh.
That's my invention, see.
Classic oven mitts,
they're big and clumsy.
So I cut out windows
in the mitts.
That way, you can
use your fingers
while you're still
using the mitts.
Great idea, huh?
TODD KERPELMAN: Wow.
This seems incredibly dangerous.
Have you tried this yourself?
MALE SPEAKER: Well, no.
I'm not much of a cook.
I'm more of what you call
an oven mitt builder.
Anyway, enjoy the oven mitts.
Oven mitts for sale.
Oven mitts.
TODD KERPELMAN: Huh.
So maybe there's a lesson here.
If you spend all your
time building tools
and don't actually use
them once in awhile,
you can't really be
sure they're any good.
I'm just going to put
these down over here.
See, we at Google don't want
to end up like our oven mitt
selling friend, and that,
in a roundabout way,
explains why we released
a game about pie throwing
to the Google Play Store.
Now, if you haven't
checked it out yet,
"Pie Noon" is a fast
paced action game
where you square off against
your friends in a pie throwing
showdown.
It's built by our Fund
Propulsion Lab's team,
the same folks behind such
hits as the LiquidFun physics
engine.
But it does raise some
important questions,
like why is Google making games?
Are we starting a game studio?
What's up with that?
Well, no.
For starters, the monetization
model is terrible.
I mean, come on.
Where are the micro
transactions folks?
No.
We really made "Pie Noon"
because we've been making some
great new tools for
C++ game developers,
but we figured maybe it's
time we put our money where
our mouth is-- when
it's not full of pie--
and demonstrate using some of
these tools in a full blown
game.
Then we can open
source the project
and let you see how
we did everything.
So let's go over some of this
tech we used one at a time.
First up, WebP.
WebP is a new graphical
format designed
to keep your image file sizes
tiny without sacrificing
quality.
Now, some people mistakenly
think that WebP is just
for web pages.
Maybe it's the word web
right there in the name.
But it's not.
You can use it in
mobile apps as well.
WebP supports lossy and
lossless compression
with lossless alpha channel
support in both cases,
and it will give you
considerable size improvements
over both JPEG and PNG files.
Remember, graphic
assets can often
be the single largest
component of your game,
and not everybody is downloading
your game over 4G networks
onto 32 gig devices.
For many people,
bandwidth and file sizes
are still real concerns, and the
smaller you can make your game,
the more likely people
are to install and keep it
on their device.
For "Pie Noon," our
engineers started with target
files, converted
those to PNG assets,
and then converted
those to WebP format.
It was these
converted files that
got used as the final
assets in the game.
And how'd it turn out?
What started as, woo, 42 meg
of [? TGAs ?] became 10.7 meg
of PNGs and ended up as a
nice, slim 1.4 meg of WebPs.
In case you're curious,
we went for lossy textures
with a quality
rating of 90, which
gave us a good balance
between size and quality.
You can judge the visual
quality for yourself
in the game or just experiment
with our conversion tool
and see what option
looks best for you.
Now granted, you can still
take this a step further
and export everything using
GPU optimize textures, which
we still highly recommend.
But I know some
developers don't want
to deal with multiple texture
formats for different chipsets,
and for those people, WebP
is a great alternative.
Next, up let's
talk about MathFu.
MathFu is a cross platform C++
library designed to quickly
and easily perform common
mathematical tasks that game
developers encounter.
So if you've got matrices
that need multiplying,
or quaternions that need
slurping, or just need
a randomly generated vector,
MathFu could help you out.
Now granted, there are many math
libraries out there like this.
But what differentiates MathFu
from any of these others
is twofold.
First, it's optimized
for SIMD chips,
like the one that is probably
in your phone right now.
And this is pretty significant.
On a Nexus 5, you're looking
at about a 5x speedup
just by using the
SIMD optimization.
On a desktop machine,
it's more like 20x.
Second, MathFu was
designed from the outset
to be simple and streamlined.
The developers did not throw
in the kitchen sink here.
They kept it focused
just on performing tasks
that game developers need.
So if you're looking
for a math library
to help you fold
proteins or something,
you should not use MathFu.
There are better libraries
out there for you.
But if you're looking
to make a game,
this will cover
all of your needs.
And again, this was something
the "Pie Noon" team set out
to prove.
The developers used
it for everything
from the particle system,
to the camera positioning,
to the parabolic pie paths,
and it worked great for that.
Finally, do you have
level data, animation
files, or saved game
data in your game
that you are defining as
a giant block of JSON?
Well, if you do, stop it.
Seriously.
Stop it.
Stop right now.
Step away from the text editor.
Look, JSON is great for
producing human readable data.
But in order to make
things human readable,
you end up having to use a
lot more space than you would
use otherwise, and
in many languages,
your JSON to native
code decoder is
going to be slow thanks to all
the string parsing and type
guessing work your
decoder needs to do.
Not only that, but the
deserialization process
is probably going to wreak
havoc with your memory
as a lot of temporary objects
are allocated and deallocated.
So to fix this problem, Google
created a serialization library
called FlatBuffers.
This is an open source tool
where you write out a schema
describing your data, and the
flap buffers library generates
a C++ file that can convert a
byte array to a native object
and back without even
having to unpack it,
meaning that zero superfluous
objects are allocated
to memory.
It's fast, way faster than
reading in JSON files.
It works cross platform,
it's [? strongly ?]
typed to avoid
careless mistakes,
and even has some
nice versioning
support when you need to
change your data format.
So the "Pie Noon"
team use FlatBuffers
to define everything from the
location of their UI elements,
to their particle
effects, to storing
all of their gameplay settings.
But are you ready
for the big twist?
They authored these
values using JSON files.
So OK giant circle with
the slash through it.
You can go away now.
Here you go.
Look at that.
You see, an intermediary step
in the build process takes
a FlatBuffer schema and
a corresponding JSON file
and converts the entire
thing into a byte array,
which can quickly be read
in as a native object
by the generated C++ file
when the game starts.
So you can check out the
CMakeLists file on the project
if you're interested in
viewing all the dirty details.
But I think the point
to take away here
is that the team got the
convenience of still being
able to author in a
human readable format,
but the speed of nearly native
code by using FlatBuffers.
Now, this speed boost was huge
from a relative standpoint.
FlatBuffers are like 400
times faster than JSON.
But in absolute numbers,
it was actually modest
just because this game didn't
have a lot of data to load.
So this whole speedup
was pretty minor
compared to everything else
the game had to do at start up.
But if your game happens to
have large amounts of game data
or save files, this can save
you a ton of loading time.
So there is some other
tech the team used,
like the build all Android
script, which ended up
being really useful to
quickly iterate on a build,
and a CPU profiler,
which frankly ended up
being not so useful because the
game was actually GPU bound.
But that's a whole
other episode.
Anyway, if you're interested
in finding out more
about any of these
technologies, we
have a whole list
of links for you
to follow in the
description below.
But more importantly, we have
a link to the full project
so you can try it
out for yourself,
fool around with
the code, and build
your own version of "Pie Noon."
So you give it a try and enjoy.
As for me, I'm going to enjoy
this delicious fresh baked pie.
Holy mother of God, that's hot.
Oh.
Like I said, you can spend
your days building tools,
but unless you use them
yourselves once in awhile,
you might get burned, literally.
I'm Todd Kerpelman,
and I'll see you soon.
MALE SPEAKER: You know what I
love about working at Google?
It's that no day is
exactly the same.
Every day brings its own unique
challenges and surprises.
For example--
MALE SPEAKER: You guys put your
phones on silent and then--
TODD KERPELMAN: No
one calls me anyway.
MALE SPEAKER: Sure they do.
TODD KERPELMAN: Wrong numbers.
I ask them to talk to me.
MALE SPEAKER: Hey, Todd.
I'm just checking.
Does that smell OK?
TODD KERPELMAN: What?
I think it smells fine.
Why?
I hate you Jeff.